When it comes to reports and visuals in Power BI,
I'd like to think of all of them in the context
of each of them being filters or measures.
With the relationships in place from our data model,
we can now get started on the report including
any necessary calculations and measures that will go within it.
So what's a report and what
does it have to do with everything that we just built up in the data model?
Well, one way to think of it is that it reflects
the data in the model plus whatever filters are applied.
If you take a single value from your list of
field options and plop it into the reporting pane,
you'll get the total for the entire field.
We can add filters in a number of spots,
starting with the most obvious, the filter pane,
which gives you the flexibility to apply filters for a single visual an entire page.
So if you've noticed those tabs at the bottom of Power BI,
each of those constitute a page,
or for all the report pages within your PBIX file.
One way to think of those fact and dimension columns that we were looking at
a little bit earlier is that the dimensions generally apply
the filters where the facts provide the values that get calculated
either through explicit or implicit measures as defined by those filters.
Everything that you add to a reporting pane will be a reflection of
not only the raw materials in your data model but also
the additional filters you add to the report itself.
So you can add visuals to your report and think of
those visuals such as a pie chart as having groups that function as filters.
Imagine in a pie chart where you have
multiple different categories breaking up parts of the whole.
You can have a table with rows and columns that are functioning as filters of the data,
slicing and dicing it accordingly and you can use visuals called slicers that provide
end-users an easy functionality to select filters that you can use in the report itself.
While we won't be touching deeply on the reporting pane,
it's important to understand the mechanics of
these filters and measures and how they interact so
that you can get
the reporting visualizations that you need and troubleshoot them accordingly.